well reject nation at midnight tonight
the final episode
of season one of loki airs
so with that in mind we'll be checking
out new rockstar's
loki final villain top eight suspect's
full investigation we have our thoughts
let's see what's going on here
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as we look ahead to the loki
finale who the hell is in that castle at
the end of time who created the dva in
its timekeeper robots and are we
guaranteed to be browse boners
well i wanted to make my best arguments
for and against
all top eight suspects hopefully we can
all
go into this finale more open-minded for
the possibilities rather than clinging
to one expectation that some might base
their enjoyment of this whole show on
the validity of
look folks kang and mephisto might heat
up a party but you don't need them for
an enjoyable night of tabletop gaming
i think i know what that means let's
start with suspect number one kang the
conqueror aka immortus aka nathaniel
richards aka the pharaoh rama tut how
many of these are there aka mr gryffin
head of king enterprises the company
that overtakes stark tower in the comics
and the latest loki easter egg pointing
in the direction of kang
now many skeptical viewers are comparing
kang to mephisto in one division just
another goofy big bad from the comics
that nerds are making mountains out of
easter egg molehills to justify
i mean that could be the case but the
truth is there are far
more clues pointing to kang's arrival
than we ever had for mephisto with
mephisto
our evidence was cryptic mentions of
devils and demon spawns satanic imagery
and parallels to a comic storyline in
which mephisto was the villain behind it
all but by episode 7 of the show the
series revealed it was agatha all along
but with loki
very different situation headed into the
finale we do not have an agatha all
along yet there's still
some man behind the curtain and unlike
the pistol hang the conqueror has been
confirmed and cast in the mcu
and uh spoiler warning for black widow
seriously if you haven't seen it skip
the next 10 seconds or so marvel studios
just proved it's not afraid to introduce
big names first on disney plus shows
with mystery woman val appearing on the
falcon the winter soldier before
her cameo now in black widow but let's
not forget that val
cameo was supposed to first appear in
black widow
before falcon and winter soldier that
was originally slated prior
yeah it wasn't intentional i bet they
think they're lucky stars once the
disney shows worry hits they're like
okay this will introduce it just as
effectively just gotta point out that
caveat there okay of all the tva judges
in the comics they could have chosen the
writers picked ravona rinslayer arguably
best known as kang's romantic interest
similarly eliath the writers could have
made up a smoke monster or picked any
number of lesser beasts from marvel lore
and they chose the one best known for
threatening kang's temporal empire the
void's possession of the pyramids and
the sphinx mirrors the historical
trophies kang keeps in his chronopolis
kingdom the central timekeeper that the
cinematography
keeps focusing on looks like an android
kang could have made in his own image
kang prime in the comics does reside at
the end of time where
this citadel is located and loki is a
time travel series
kang is marvel's ultimate villain it
just lines up now if the void is made up
of things that the tva
pruned and if kang were running the tva
why would they prune things from a kang
dominated timeline well if the tva is
all kang's machinery the void's true
purpose could be to collect things that
kang
actually wants and goliath could be the
snake in his garden that kang needed
silvie
kang could to slay tva prisoner kept in
solitary confinement and eliath was
keeping him there
look it might not be kang but anyone who
says that it's definitely not kang
is either dismissing a very likely
possibility for just being too
obvious to them kind of like what mobius
said it's always the game within the
game with you guys
which i respect or people are just
afraid of looking wrong after mephisto
to which i say if you like this stuff
this much being right isn't going to
make you cool
so just be the greater fool and own it
and that brings us to suspect
two real quick though i'm constantly
back and forth i've sold myself
and we talked extensively about this in
our spoiler discussion of the last
episode so i'll keep it very brief here
i ultimately don't
think it will be kang yet i won't be
surprised if it is count i'll be like
okay cool let's get it but i just don't
think it's going there for them to
introduce this super villain this big
baddie
in the final episode of this show when
the only way you would know that is if
you've read the comics and i feel like
for there to be a big reveal just within
the context of the
show itself would have to be something
where audiences who don't even read the
commercial would be like
oh dang i should have guessed that yeah
you know not that it should be obvious
but more like that's a good reveal
that's how good reveals work because i
should have seen that coming
yeah so you at least have a chance to
piece together or go back and look at
the kernels of
king loki trailer footage shots still
yet to be shown on the series
show a smug loki on the throne of asgard
that's who i am
in stark tower redoing the events of the
battle of new york
glorious we know that tva targets loki's
in particular and since this show is
about loki variants it would make
sense for the man behind the curtain to
be some alpha loki
who created the tva in order to erase
all other variant competitors to his
rule and one who would represent the
darkest parts of loki's soul that our
protagonist has been battling
internally now you could also say this
might contradict the trajectory the
series has been following right like
each episode introduces us to
increasingly diverse loki variants
each with a different face from a female
to an old man to a kid to a reptile so
to pull back the final curtain just to
reveal the
face of tom hiddleston again i mean i
don't know loki just did that in episode
5
opening the hatch to president loki and
then shortly after the show turned him
into a kind of a joke so it might seem
like a step
backward to reveal yet another tom
hiddleston loki
but evil this time even though we spent
two and a half movies with that version
of the character already folks these
trailer shots could just be visions of a
hypothetical timeline in which loki
rules as king
illusions conjured by whoever is behind
the curtain to try to tempt loki
i don't fully agree with what eric just
said because i still think
thematically it lines up pretty
well yeah you've pointed out that this
shows so much about like
self-confrontation and all that i think
that'd be a pretty crazy reveal actually
yeah the whole time we're trying to take
down the big bad behind the tva you know
you go to this
the void and it seems like it's mainly
just loki's yeah absolutely
to me it would be kind of crazy though
like oh my god the person would try to
take down
and then you end the show with a pro a
good loki and a
evil loki what if it actually was the
loki behind infinity war what if he had
classic loki's story and ended up
surviving plus i don't know i mean like
we've seen so many other loki's that are
a joke would be kind of a
also reversal on that dynamic to have
one who really did
build this like incredible machination
through time and space that he is the
superior loki that exactly the
variant loki the one who didn't die but
the one who survived in won
since loki's are destined to usually
lose yeah now just to cover our bases we
could look at suspect number three
mobius with his perceived
inconsistencies of not remembering
leaving ring stains not remembering an
alligator loki as a sign that there
could be some other mobius variant or
mobius could be a loki variant but it
does seem like owen wilson was cast on
this show to be a foil to
loki not to be some maniacal crazy big
bad
he seems like he's there to represent
the aw shocks in a sense of the tva
workforce and of course to ride a jet
ski really for it to matter that some
characters are loki variants
a lot of the other characters must not
be loki variants there's only so many
times you can play that card i mean yeah
i see you say that would be a mobius
variant yeah basically
i don't think so i mean i could see a
scenario where it could hold some weight
maybe if they do some kind of v who
remains tie-in with him or something
like that like what makes him the most
special i can imagine something i think
whatever it is has to complete its story
context-wise more than anything else
yeah more than big universe buildings
yes similarly suspect number four
rent slayer already has a role to play
in uncovering this mystery
so to reveal a rinse layer variant
behind the curtain might
muddy the current rinse layer arc and
set up a weird ren slayer versus red
slayer conflict is that how we want the
show to end now there is suspect number
five
casey not seen since episode let it be
the name casey
is a clue k c
i'm sorry i'm gonna pass on that one but
suspect number six miss minutes is worth
considering
i would love it if it is casey i would i
would be very happy
just sitting on a mountain of infinity
stones
at the end of time oh man that'd be
hilarious i mean it would it would upset
so many people
but the biggest ralph boner of all we
still don't know what she
is like she can transcend both digital
screens and real space
and she is close enough to the heart of
the tva to access confidential records
and
lie on behalf of it and tara strong
teased that there's so much more to be
revealed and that you don't really know
who she is where she's from what her
origin story is
how sentient she is miss minutes could
be the public face of whoever is
controlling the tva
and silvi's vision glided up to that lit
tower and stopped at its golden glow
maybe connected to the color of miss
minutes and in this case the one
controlling the tva might be
no one and it's all part of some
self-perpetuating clockwork with
mechanized puppet authorities but what
threw me was the way these android
timekeepers laughed
one of them pretty weird response i read
that as some maniacal puppet master who
might have even
wanted loki and sylvia to make this
discovery and that brings us to suspect
number seven
dr doom before we dive into doctor dylan
this missed minutes thing see if you
look at tara strong's quote
yes she's saying you can cryptically
tease that you'll see her again and that
there's much more
to reveal and that it's fun to watch
that unfold i don't know how much of
that really pertains to
knowing who or what miss minutes is
she's doing this whole description i
felt like that was more of a comment
on why she loves playing this character
miss minutes how there's so much she can
fill in the blank for on herself that
there's so much not really known about
her character
it's the one i like i'm not on board
with not because i'm
like angry at the thought about it i
don't believe it it'd
actually be the one i'd be the most like
oh wow i'm surprised how wrong i'd be
the most surprised
at how wrong i was about that one to be
honest
yeah i have the most trouble justifying
it in my mind and i do think that also
potentially with the amount of things
that get leaked about these shows
probably that marvel doesn't want maybe
they let her kind of have fun with this
as a means of muddying the water and
getting us
further from the truth honestly her
answer sounds like a misdirect in so
many ways
yeah it could be a teaser maybe it's
just like this is a new character
created for this show so i can kind of
do whatever i want and that's really fun
for me dr
doom whom some are connecting to the
european looking castle
the androids they say being similar to
doombots and the possibility that
sorcery could have been used to enchant
the tva to block out the other forms of
magic but unlike kang
doom has not yet been cast or even
confirmed for the mcu he's coming
someday but probably not in the next few
years i think the people who are pushing
for doctor doom are just comic readers
who find king too confusing but in my
breakdown i brought up suspect number
eight classic location i like justin
really he might have faked his death
with goliath similar to the way he
confessed to faking his death with
thanos
i like this better than king loki
because it still checks those boxes of
loki basing an alpha variant of himself
while letting richard grant continue to
shine think about it classic loki is
insanely powerful he casts complex
duplicates creating teleportation
portals conjuring a full
asgard emerald city illusion and in his
final seconds
as he was wiped away by eliath he let
his green magic fade from his hands and
he was laughing and glee and notice how
his cape
seemed to dematerialize before eliath
got to him
i'm definitely getting some vibes of
obi-wan surrendering to vader to become
more powerful than you can possibly
imagine and classic loki had that
interesting response to mobius earlier
so just like that you're turning on the
very thing you devoted your life to
it's never too late to change it's just
hard to tell with him because grant is
so good an
actor he replaced that single tear as
light and wind pounded his face
which could have been him accepting his
fate or feeling a kind of excitement for
a different long-awaited release
now you may be asking why would classic
loki slum it in the void if he was
really running the tva from that castle
beyond well if we're really going by the
man behind the curtain logic
classic loki's theatrical costume could
be a
duplicate illusion exactly what i'm
about to say
that's exactly what i have to say the
only thing that can subdue eliath is
enchantment the one form of sorcery that
he does not appear to have
because unlike loki l1130 and sylvie he
never had a connection with another he
lived his whole life alone on a remote
planet
that could be why he wanted sylvie and
loki to come here why the timekeepers
laughed
why loki's have been targeted i think
whoever is the man behind the curtain
once they bet is that they will refer to
themselves as he who remains that's the
title of the elderly tva agent at the
end of time who engineers the
timekeepers and i say that because
really any of these suspects could be he
who remains
or he who remains might just be a
completely new face or even just
a note left by a guy named he who
remains on a miss minutes wall clock
connected to a bunch of cogs and levers
reading out to lunch see you in a minute
and based on all of the evidence folks
it's just hard not to imagine that
whoever it is
if it's not kang it must have been
someone who created the tva at the
behest of or in response to
kang like even if gang is reduced to a
post-credit cameo or no sighting at all
his fingerprints are all over the series
and we're not talking devils in the
details
these are intentional clues definitely
so if you are still in the kang gang
after all this
i will be there with you because
mephisto's getting lonely in my daily
mentions
so where am i at i i guess i'll say
classic loki he who remains in a rivalry
against kang with miss minutes as his
automated assistant but i'm not putting
the house on that
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following subscribe to new
rockstars this is my final loki theory
video before the finale so i will see
all of you on the other side till season
two awesome said many times that
regardless of the actual villain is
in the show it's still building to king
to conquer
it has planted the seeds for king to
conquer the most apparently
so you're still right even if it's not
right now yeah exactly
yeah and i wouldn't mind like a little
kane cameo like in a post-credits scene
or something
yeah since the post criticisms are
usually designed to set
up an upcoming installment of the marvel
cinematic universe he can look up and
grin
actually you know it would be kind of
cool because adventures ends with
after loki was the main villain ends
with setting up thanos the real big
baddie of the mcu now that thanos is
gone loki the series could end
and set up for king the conqueror and
loki will just live out his destiny
setting up for the new big yeah
for the next phase of the mcu all right
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell keep a lookout
for our loki episode 6 reaction should
be up in
hopefully less than 24 hours from when
this video has been uploaded and let's
do a pic
justin i bet it's you at the end of time
you know why because you're so
mysterious all i know about you is that
your name
is justin and there are a lot of great
justin's out there justin
lin our friend justin karanugan you but
justin i mean
listen if you are the big bad at the end
of
all this all right how are you going to
explain yourself to the people
all right how are you going to keep
yourself hygienic by nail clipping
that's how
you are judicious you are universal
you are substantial you are tenacious
got to get a better word than that next
time you are indelible
and you are nutritious just thinking
about you
here in this moment i feel enriched and
i feel empowered about my life so hey
it doesn't matter what the ultimate
answer is justin it's about the friends
we made along the way and i'm glad
you're one of them thank you for
sticking around for all of our silliness
and for supporting us
both here on youtube and on patreon it
means a lot hope you're doing well
be well oh my god
[Music]
you